[Music]
there's nothing like a nice savory meal
but you might want to put that fork down
and how you've seen this video it may
spoil your appetite but you'll thank us
later if you're new here be sure to
subscribe to the things - stay in the
loop and reach over there and tap the
like button - now prepare to be
astonished about these 10 foods you'll
never buy again after knowing how
they're made we are still having
nightmares about number one don't worry
that's not a worm it's just a mold
string oh wait that's definitely a worm
Capri Suns are supposed to be a sweet
fruity drink inside a fun silver pouch
so imagine one kid surprised when he
poked the straw in took a big gulp and
choked on a worm which came up through
the straw disgusting when the family
contacted craft the makers of Capri Sun
they got a rather interesting letter
back from the company they said they
surmised that what the boy and his
mother called a worm may actually be
mold the company then bragged about the
fact that mold may grow inside these
drink pouches because their drinks are
made without preservatives they said
that's something many moms like you're
kidding right we're pretty sure all moms
are against moldy beverages for their
kids this isn't the first case of worms
in these drink pouches many other kids
have found worms in their fruity punch -
we checked out one of our news stories
with pictures and were 1,000% sure
that's a worm what do you guys think but
even if it was a mold ooh that doesn't
make it much better either way we're
going to steer clear of drink pouches
and blindly drinking from containers
that we can't see through no worm juice
for us
thanks B P ain't eatin that again if you
like canned tomatoes and tomato soup
you're not going to like this fact we
found researchers have discovered that
the lining of some cans contain a
chemical called
B spino a or BPA you might have noticed
that a lot of baby products and plastic
bottles now say bpa-free on them that's
because there have been studies linking
BPA to brain behavior reproductive
system and prostate problems especially
in children and fetuses when it was
first synthesized in the early 1900s
BPA was used as a synthetic estrogen
later it was combined with
people called phosgene to make toxic gas
during World War one yikes
that explains why this chemical has been
linked to a whole slew of health
problems the good news is BPA gets
locked into chemical bonds during the
manufacturing process the bad news is
that BPA can get unlocked and leak when
it's exposed to heat or acidic foods
like tomatoes when scientists said that
even the smallest exposure can put your
health at risk so you may want to put
those cans down and squash some fresh
tomatoes yourself just put them in a
barrel and squash them with your toes
the way they squash wine grapes fun for
the whole family
cheap sweat chewing gum they always look
so happy in gum commercials don't they
the sun is shining someone's writing a
colorful bike everyone is laughing hold
up guys you might not be laughing as
much when you find out what's in that
piece of bubble gum it's an ingredient
called lanolin which is a gooey oily
secretion found in sheep's wool the FDA
approved it for use as an additive that
softens chewing gum that's it
we are spitting out our gum and
sanitizing our tongues anything
involving the word secretion doesn't
belong anywhere in our mouths this left
us scratching our heads it really got us
wondering who in the world thought it
would be a good idea to put sheep grease
in bubble gum we want to know how this
person knew sheep grease was even a
thing what's he doing to those sheep and
why is he messing with our chewing gum
get this shepherd a new hobby seriously
that's gross dude and it gets worse even
if you spit out your gum you might have
rubbed sheep grease all over your face
today
that's because lanolin can also be found
in beauty products and sunscreen it's
supposed to be good for moisturizing the
skin we think we're gonna pass on the
sheep secretion artificial sweeteners
many diet foods and drinks are made with
artificial sweeteners if the label says
sugar free chances are the food product
was made with one of the five main
artificial sweeteners in it the FDA has
approved saturon acesulfame aspartame
mio tame and sucralose for public
consumption
well folks believe that consuming these
sweeteners in place of sugar is a
healthy choice studies show they are
wrong these sweeteners are way more
potent than regular sugar which
overloads the taste buds and receptors
in the brain
over time this overload can cause
typical healthy foods like fruits and
vegetables to become very bland tasting
or even completely unpalatable this in
turn causes people to seek out more
salty and sugary foods which kind of
defeats the whole purpose and these
sweeteners are highly addictive when lab
rats were given a choice between crack
and saturon they went with the Saturn
and it turns out these sweeteners have
been linked to an increased risk of
obesity type 2 diabetes and
cardiovascular disease just one diet
drink a day is enough to significantly
increase the risk of developing these
health problems it's kind of like
smashing your hands with a hammer to
help with a cut on your finger did an
Alanis Morissette write a song about
this sawdust Parmesan sawdust Parmesan
sounds like something a termite or a
beaver might enjoy but not us
cheese-loving Americans there's an
ingredient that is put into shredded
cheeses such as parmesan that keeps it
from sticking together
it's called cellulose and is derived
from plants and wood pulp the truth is
this ingredient isn't really that
harmful but it can be misleading in fact
two years ago authorities cracked a big
case of missing cheese
apparently investigators paid a surprise
visit to castle cheese incorporated to
sniff out some clues what did they
discover these t's cooks were up to no
Gouda get it Gouda anyhoo they found out
the castle cheese was doctoring they're
shredded cheese's with a ton of fillers
such as wood pulp and other cheaper
cheeses and selling it to consumers as
100% Parmesan GRA gorgonzola these
grated Parmesan suppliers were
mislabeling their products and fooling
customers with these cheesy imposters
they're president of castle cheese
Michele murder pled guilty and was
sentenced to five years probation for
the cheese caper and while it seems
everything works out in the end it's
going to be hard to trust those shredded
cheese labels again we hope castle
cheese will be more careful in the
future
we love a good cheese bun waiter there's
a hair in my bread if you buy your bread
in a prepackaged bag from the store
you're gonna want to hear this one take
a look at the ingredients on the back of
the bread bag you'll probably see an
ingredient on there called l-cysteine
what is that well we found out that
l-cysteine is an amino acid which is
used in dough conditioners to soften and
preserve
mass-produce breads we've bet you've
already guessed what it's made of
yep human hair and sometimes duck
feathers and cow horns and Pig bristles
here's the really gross part most of the
hair they use to make our bread comes
from the floors of hair salons in China
okay suddenly that's Tam which isn't
looking so good anymore so they take the
clumps of hair from the Chinese
hairdressers soak them in acid and
poured the acid hair juice into bread
dough that gets baked and bags before it
makes its way to your table for hoagie
night fun fact that bread you just put
in your mouth started out as a clump on
a dirty floor and was stepped on
repeatedly as women gossiped about
Justin Bieber seconds anyone this gives
a whole new meaning to the term hot
cross buns toilet bowl potato chips
anyone did you know that there is an
ingredient in potato chips that is also
used in most toilet bowl--cleaning
agents sodium Bissell fights can with
the shine on your toilet seat and extend
the life of your potato chips all while
getting rid of any nasty chipped
discoloration when we heard this one we
couldn't help but think of a story of
some aristocratic snob telling her
servants to do whatever it takes to
ensure there will be no brown spots on
her potato chips here's something you
might not know about this potato chip
ingredient sodium Bissell fight is a
chemical they use as a food preservative
and it smells like rotten eggs
it's also used to make paper and leather
products as well as toilet bowl cleaner
according to the New Jersey Department
of Health this substance is corrosive
and produces poisonous gases when heated
in a fire it can burn the skin and eyes
and can cause a skin an asthma like
allergy now whose big idea was it to use
this on potato chips we can tell you one
thing if it's on the state of New
Jersey's hazardous back sheets it's not
going anywhere near our mouths wait does
this mean we can clean the toilet with
potato chips popcorn confessions imagine
it's Friday night and you're about to
see the Black Panther movie on the big
screen what could be more perfect than a
big hot tub of buttery popcorn well if
you're looking for real butter on that
popcorn your going to have to smuggle it
in yourself
that's because movie theaters don't use
butter for their popcorn anymore
it turns out they haven't used butter
for a while what are they use instead
it's a blend of partially hydrogenated
oil or trans fats beta-carotene and
something called TBHQ for those of you
who don't know what TBHQ is it's a food
additive that is also used in paints and
varnishes but it also keeps your
high-fat oils from getting rancid aside
from the fact that this butter
substitute has 20% more calories than
regular butter and has also been linked
to cancer as tumors in rats so if you
get a large popcorn with three
tablespoons of butter and a soda you
could be over 2,000 calories which is
what we're supposed to take in for the
whole day and you could wind up with a
tumor pack yellow sludge does look kind
of gross now that we thought about it
maybe we'll just get some chocolate
instead there's nothing wrong with
chocolate right oh no no chocolate -
it's nothing sacred chocolate has been
hailed as a triumph of the soul and
natural aphrodisiac a mood and energy
booster and a girl's best friend but
this mouth-watering heavenly treat just
might be delivering more than meets the
eye we encourage you to be on your guard
when you are enjoying that box of
chocolates from your Valentines when you
bite into a creamy chocolate covered
caramel you might be getting a bit more
than you bargained for
and we're not talking about the
boyfriend you could find an unwanted
surprise in your chocolate kisses no
it's not a diamond ring it's rodent hair
the FDA allows one rat hair per 100
grams of chocolate so will you be the
lucky recipient and that's not all the
FDA says food products can contain a
small amount of other foreign matter -
what's considered acceptable foreign
matter cigarette busts mammalian
droppings fruit flies maggots and stick
parts we created a new game for when we
are eating chocolate treats we're
calling it is that a nut or foreign
matter we really hope it tonight
otherwise we'll have to face the notion
that somewhere in the Chocolate Factory
there's a cigarette smoking rats singing
and dancing and drinking from Willy
Wonka's chocolate fountain brace
yourselves for this one after you see
this you'll never look at a porkchop the
same way again warning the icky factor
for this one is off the charts
so here's what happened last Christmas
this dude in Tampa was enjoying a nice
pork dinner a couple of months later he
kept see
in this little black spot in his eye he
decided to get it checked out by a
doctor and that's when he discovered the
most disgusting thing we've ever heard
that black dot was a brain-eating
tapeworm that was swimming around in the
fluid inside his eye and that's not even
a worst event this slimy parasite was
pregnant with fifty thousand eggs just
waiting to be laid inside the guy's
skull
if the eggs had hatched they could have
traveled to his brain and began to eat
it pause for gagging they got the worm
out before the eggs hatched it's a good
thing too these brain eating worms can
cause seizures and weakness in the legs
why does undercooked pork carry these
horrifying parasites you asked because
the pigs are fed rotten garbage which
are full of bacteria and parasites
this worm filled pork then travels from
the farm to your table and eventually
into your brain if you hope this doesn't
give you nightmares
then at least now you know and that's it
for the ten foods you'll never buy again
after knowing how they're made thanks
for joining us here at the things see
you next time
[Music]